how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
[Music]
Michael Morbius at I'm doing a little
good guy hang up sometime welcome back
everyone it's Charlie this is gonna be
my new spider-man Morbius trailer video
for all the sinister six stuff that
they're setting up if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we're doing a new
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your sinister six theories on the
video so the Morbius trailer shows us a
couple of spider-man scenes between the
wall graffiti of the Tobey Maguire
spider-man suit referencing the Spider
Man far from home post-credit scene
murderer like he killed Mysterio or at
least the world thinks he killed
Mysterio then I would argue the even
bigger scene of Michael Keaton's vulture
after the events of the spider-man
homecoming post-credit scene in his same
white prison jumpsuit in New York City
which itself might be from one of the
Morbius post-credit scenes there's also
a Kraven seemed that didn't make it into
the trailer remember we're all thinking
the Kraven might be the villain to the
next spider-man movies spider-man 3
which they're shooting this summer
there's this truck that reads teasing
that the characters gonna show up Earl
soon but because it's showing up in
Morbius a Sony movie not an MCU movie
there's a big question about where
Kraven is going to appear first because
Sony is developing a Kraven solo film so
I'm not so sure that Kraven is gonna be
the villain of spider-man 3 but it's
just all more evidence of them setting
up sinister 6 off in the distance in
fact on the spider-man far from home
bonus features there's a clip of Amy
Pascal literally saying that they're
getting ready to do something with the
sinister six these villains that we now
have in our universe happen to be
characters that are in the sinister six
there may be something that happens to
that no matter where he goes the world
is gonna be different for him here's the
real blockbuster
brace yourselves you might want to sit
out spider-man's name is Peter Parker
what no more hiding yeah no more hiding
I feel like you watch that and it can't
be any more clear they're definitely
headed for sinister six Sony has a
history to of putting footage from the
end of their movies in their trailers if
he didn't notice they did it with venom
last year and all the venom trailers
they kept having that clip of him
talking about turds in the wind eating
that guy in the convenience store that
was right out of the end of the venom
movies so it wasn't really them giving
away the post-credits scene it's just a
lot of people feel like this vulture
Michael Keaton cameo is from the end of
the movie like you go through the
process of him becoming the Morpheus
character then this will be some sort of
tag scene to let you know that it's all
connected blowing everyone's minds but
they put it in the trailer because they
really want you to go see the movie to
find out what's going on on top of all
this there's also a lot of people now
after watching the trailer who are
wondering if Jerrod Harris's Morbius
character is in fact secretly a really
big spider-man villain from the comics
he comes off like a caring father figure
to Morbius in the trailer but Sony is
being very secretive about the official
name of his character and the only
reason to do that would be if it's a big
spoiler and if he's playing a huge
spider-man villain like a lot of people
are now wondering if he might secretly
be their new version of dr. Otto
Octavius because they're only a few big
spider-man villains who are doctors
themselves and it does seem like his
character is a medical doctor and even
though a lot of spider-man villains come
from the sciences like Norman Osborn is
a scientist he's not a real doctor in
the way Doctor Octopus is and you have
to remember that Doctor Octopus is
actually the person who put together the
first version of the sinister 16 Norman
Osborn's Green Goblin didn't really get
tied up with sinister six stuff till way
way later in the comics but they just
did the lizard a few years ago during
the Andrew Garfield amazing spider-man
movies and the whole thing with the new
Tom Hollands spider-man era of movies is
them doing new characters or people they
haven't done in a long time in yes they
did do Doctor Octopus doing the Tobey
Maguire films but if they're using
Toby's suit for this big spider-man
spider-man far from home Easter egg then
maybe it is a big clue that they're
bringing back some more stuff from the
Tobey Maguire era like the Doctor
Octopus character but now you probably
realize why they wanted to put so much
of this spider-man crossover stuff in
the Morbius movie it's mostly to get you
to go see the movie to find out what's
happening
otherwise how many people do you think
would completely ignore Morbius he's not
that huge of a character and even though
venom did really well last year venom by
himself
is a really really popular character so
people were already gonna go see that
movie no matter what Sony is really
banking on this big spider verse that
they're spinning out to be successful so
they're just throwing everything they
have at these spin-off movies you never
heard of Morbius before you're not sure
about whether or not you're gonna go
well we're gonna put a whole bunch of
spider-man crossover stuff in it now how
about you go but cute pizza time we also
have to talk about this Tobey Maguire
spider-man costume why would they use
this version of the costume if they're
referencing the events of spider-man far
from home in that post-credit scene
would happen with Mysterio I think one
it's to let you know that there will be
a spider-man crossover eventually like
spider-man exists in this universe
because you didn't see him anywhere
during the first venom movie and I think
they're gonna use the venom to to
software reboot that with a bunch more
spider-man stuff but - I think it's also
meant to be a nod to the original Sony
spider-man movies with Tobey Maguire
like those were hugely successful films
however you feel about them creatively
spider-man 2 is still one of the best
spider-man movies of all time in three I
think it's also a way to remind you that
there is a spider verse in a multiverse
in a way for the MCU movies in the sonne
venom verse babies to coexist in how it
can make sense for Tom Hall to show up
in both franchises without the MCU
having to be super beholden to all the
stuff that they're doing in the venom
movies with Tom Holland things don't
really get that complicated til you
start seeing Tom Holland jump back and
forth between the Sony movies whenever
he's crossing over with venom and he's
sinister six stuff and then the MCU
movies there's still a lot of questions
about how their sinister six project
would go down will sinister six be the
next big movie after venom two or to
Sony wait and do more solo villain
movies like the Craven movie I said that
they're developing they're clearly
setting Craven up during the Morbius
movies so that means that he's going to
appear somewhere but here's what Marvel
and Sony both said about how they're
handling the spider-man Tom Holland
crossovers they announced a lot of these
details when they revealed the new
sharing deal just a little while ago
they refer to it as a call and answer
system Kevin Feige talked about
spider-man jumping back and forth
between Earth's in the multiverse but
also between cinematic
versus Tom Holland was already confirmed
to be appearing in the Sony venom movies
eventually and other potentially Sony
driven spider-man projects like sinister
six when he does that Sony is allowed to
reference his previous adventures in all
the Marvel movies that spider-man has
been in like getting snapped in Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame his
field trips with the Avengers during
Captain America Civil War in all the
Mysterio stuff during spider-man far
from home then when he comes back for
more Marvel movies like spider-man 3
Avengers 5 Young Avengers whatever the
MCU movies are allowed to reference all
the stuff that happened to him while he
was in the Sony venom movies so if he
gets the symbiote during one of the
venom sequels are doing a big venom
crossover they can reference the
symbiote in the MCU movies after that a
lot of you will remember a way back to
spider-man homecoming the MCU movies
already kind of seemed like they were
slowly building their own roster of
sinister six characters starting in the
post-credits scene it's on our little
spider friend I've got some boys on the
outside who would love to meet him you
know take a picture slice his throat put
his head in a dryer and I heard a rumor
you know who is the thing about that
post credit scene is that after the
events of spider-man far from home we
mostly assumed that we'd be seeing an
MCU only version of sinister six
but with Michael Keaton showing up at
the end of Morbius it seemingly confirms
that we'll see at least some of the
sinister six stuff come from the Sony
venom versed movies so I don't know if
this is gonna be a joint venture with
the MCU because sinister six is a big
deal and Sony has been trying to make a
sinister six movie since way back in the
Andrew Garfield era that was with a
whole amazing spider-man to post-credit
scene was about oscorp's sinister six
then Drew Goddard the person who started
the daredevil Netflix TV show was
actually gonna direct the sinister six
movie but then they got rid of Andrew
Garfield and basically shelved their
plans for sinister six so I still think
that they're chomping at the bit to make
a sinister six movie but because of the
vulture showing up in Morbius it
seemingly confirms that venom will also
eventually have a presence in whatever
sinister six movie that they eventually
do and I think a lot of what the new
sinister six movie would wind up looking
like and how everything goes down just
depends on whether or not Marvel makes
the sinister six movie or Sony makes it
by themselves so let me know in the
comments do you think that sinister six
is gonna wind up being an MCU movie or
do you think it's just gonna wind up
being a Sony movie by itself there's a
bunch more Marvel videos I'll be doing
this weekend and next week so leave all
your requests in the comments below if
you have any big questions
congratulations kirie irving you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here to rewatch the full
Morbius trailer a billion more times and
everyone click here to watch the Justice
League Ezra Miller flash crossover with
the Grant Gustin flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight